and my question is a lot of people say
that your biggest strength is also your
biggest weakness or vice versa your
biggest weakness is your biggest
strength what is yours the fact that I'm
trying to understand that I'm trying to
scale the unscalable very 100% the
reason people care about me so much is
because I'm doing things that everybody
deems is not scalable so they don't do
it on the flip side calling people for
those 12 minutes didn't allow me I mean
there's like there's like a scope that I
need to approve for a client that's
gonna make us millions of dollars in
2014 that you know I've made this
mistake before where I've done the
unscalable thing and let the big thing
pass and so that is that was the easiest
question for me to answer today is the
fact that I'm trying to scale the
unscalable but you know what I feel like
I've spent most of my career trying to
do that and those things ironically the
things that that turn into the most
beautiful the most beautiful experience
the balance the seesaw it's a constant
game